c'est plutôt l'hélium liquide qui va
être dans cette température là et encore
je pas pers drôle de discussion dans un
centre commercial entre scientifiquees
passionné et le public l'espace
Saint-Quentin à Montini accueillait la
Fête de la Science les expériences se
veulent ludiqu ici par exemple on parle
du froid et de la température glace de
carbone et azote liquide des éléments à
-
180° c'est ici qu'on peut se permettre
de désacraliser des choses de faire
sortir des choses qui sont dangereuses à
peu rentre dans l'esprit dans
l'imaginaire collectif et donc de
réussir à dacraliser des points pour
faire changer une image faire évoluer
une image et permettre aux gens de se
rapprocher de quelque chose et de se
direah c'est pas parce que j'étais nul
en science et que j'étais bloqué sur les
Tabl de multiplication en CP que je suis
forcément un idiot fini trs
lo
temp c'est très intéressant ça permet
d'aider les gens à se diriger vers des
vers la science alors que ça peut
paraître assez difficile et spécifique
je trouve ça pas mal quoi c'est ça
permet aux gens de plus s'orienter vers
des des filières s parce que nous on a
plutôt des a priori d justement Ivan sa
est chercheur en pathologie végétale il
est venu aussi à la rencontre du public
une nécessité selon ce scientifique de
linra qui souligne que ces travaux sont
financés par des fonds publics les
jeunes sont attirés par la science mais
il faut arriver à le expliquer ce que
c'est et surtout la gamme des métiers
qui qui est très très large il y a pas
des chercheurs des blouses d'ailles j'en
ai pas il y a des métiers techniques il
y a des informaticiens il y a tout une
gamme de
métiers le grosi le gros plaisir que
j'ai dans ce métier c'est toutes ces
personnes travaillent ensemble on fait
pas de la science tout seul je suis
devenu chercheur parce que j'ai
rencontré des chercheurs on pris le
tempsexquer ce qu'il faisent pourquoi il
le faisait et je suis rentré dans le
métier comme
ça